[S01] 你试着想象一下这个场景啊那是1997 年在网络创世纪呃就是一款非常古老的网络游戏的开发过程中程序员在代码里意外打碎了一块承载着整个虚拟世界的魔法水晶
[S02] 对，这其实是个很有名的极客圈子里的轶事了
[S01] 是的为了让游戏能容纳众多玩家呢他们被迫将这块水晶的碎片分散到了不同的服务器上每一个碎片就运行着这个虚拟世界的一个独立部分
[S02] 他们当时大概完全没有意识到这个有点儿呃有点儿被迫为之的极客举动几乎构成了今天所有千万级并发应用能够存活的基石
[S01] 没错所以在我们今天的这项深度探讨任务里我们就要来拆解一下这本分布式系统领域的圣经《设计数据密集型应用》也就是大家常说的 DDIAA的第七章：分片我们要弄清楚当几亿人同时刷新时间线的时候数据底层到底发生了什么好的让我们来拆解一下
[S02] 嗯支撑现代互联网不坑牌的核心机制确实充满了这种怎么说呢在极限压力下逼出来的工程美学资料里提到了一句非常经典的话是计算机先驱格雷斯赫北在一九六二年说的他说我们必须跳出顺序computer指令的窠臼我们必须叙述关系而不是过程
[S01] 十九六二年哇那时候连互联网的影子都还没有吧
[S02] 对对对半个多世纪前它其实就已经预见到了单点计算的物理极限而所谓的分片也就是Sharding本质上就是我们为了突破这种物理极限对数据关系进行了一次非常暴力但又极其精密的重构
[S01] 呃提到物理极限我得在这里抛出一个可能很多人都有的疑问现在的硬件发展那简直是怪物级别的比如你在AWS或者阿里云上随手就能拉起一台有几TB内存上百个核心的超级服务器它的吞吐量已经恐怖到了极点
[S02] 确实单机性能现在非常强悍
[S01] 对吧就像是你的行李太重了你完全可以花大价钱去买一个特制的超级大背包这就是垂直扩展那为什么为什么非要雇十个人把东西分摊装进十个小背包里也就是水平扩展分布式系统意味着我们要去处理那种让人抓狂的网络延迟啊节点宕机啊引入分片这种重型武器它带来的复杂度和收益真的成正比吗
[S02] 这个是一个非常核心的质疑纯粹从算力峰值角度来看呢很多中型应用其实靠一台现代的大型云服务器真的就能跑满全场了但这里最引人肃胜的是分片的动机早就超越了单纯的性能或者容量
[S01] 哦不单单是为了性能
[S02] 对当我们把目光转向现在极其普遍的SAS架构也就是多租户场景的时候分片提供了一种单机永远无法实现的东西那就是硬隔离
[S01] 硬隔离呃你的意思是防范那些在系统里过度消耗资源的客户
[S02] 没错可以这么理解你想象一下假设你运用这一个企业协作平台后台就是一张巨大的单体数据库表你的客户里面呢既有只有十几个人的初创团队也有那种几万名员工的跨国巨头
[S01] 嗯体量超级极大
[S02] 对那如果这家跨国巨头在周一早晨突然跑了一个极其复杂的全局数据报表
[S01] 这个查询可能会瞬间吃掉数据库百分之九十的CPU和内存哇那就惨了那个十几个人的初创团队可能连发一条简单的文字消息都会一直转圈圈直接超时报错了
[S02] 没错在单体架构下所有的租户共享同一个资源池这就是典型的吵闹的邻居效应
[S01] 原来如此所以如果我们将数据进行分片就可以把这种超级大客户单独隔离开来甚至就是在物理层面上直接分配专属的服务器集群给这些特定分片
[S02] 是的大客户的报表怎么折腾也只会压榨他们自己所在分片的算力初创团队在另一个分片里依然可以享受毫秒级的丝滑体验而且更进一步说这还涉及到系统的容灾和合规性
[S01] 合规性这个怎么讲
[S02] 资料里提到了基于单元的架构你可以把某些分片的数据完全封装在一个独立的物理可用区里如果某个机房的光缆突然被挖断了只有分配到那个机房的租户会受影响
[S01] 也就是所谓的销售爆炸半径对吧
[S02] 对另外像GDPR这种极其严格的隐私法规它要求你必须能够彻底物理销毁特定用户的数据如果你所有客户的数据都纠缠在一块连续的磁盘扇区里彻底清理简直是噩梦
[S01] 呃但如果是基于分片的话就可以直接把那个对应的存储卷下线或者查除干脆利落
[S02] 完全正确所以你下一次在用企业邮箱或者各种SAS工具的时候其实底层都在用这些分片隔离机制来保护你的数据
[S01] 既然分片能带来资源隔离容灾控制还能提升吞吐量那摆在我们面前的第一个工程难题就是这蛋糕到底怎么切按照什么规则来分才能保证极其公平不至于产生那种焊的焊死烙的烙死的偏斜现象呢
[S02] 最符合人类直觉的切法呢叫做见范围分片这就好比一本传统的纸质百科全书
[S01] 呃就像第一卷是首字母A到B第二卷是C到D这样
[S02] 对对对在数据库里如果主键是用户名系统可以非常轻松的把字母表切分成几个段落然后分配给不同的节点对于范围查询来说这种切法绝对是天然友好的
[S01] 嗯如果我想找名字从A到C的所有用户信息系统直接去前面两个分片顺着磁盘扫一遍就全带回来了但是等等我发现一个漏洞如果这是一张sensor网络的数据表呢大家的主键不是名字而是时间戳
[S02] 哎你抓到重点了
[S01] 对吧那所有今天产生的新数据它们的时间戳全都是今天的日期这就意味着代表昨天前天的那些分片服务器现在全都在喝茶摸鱼而所有新来的上入的请求全挤在代表今天的那一卷里那个节点岂不是要被挤爆了
[S02] 非常敏锐这就是见范围分片最致命的弱点热点问题连续的高并发入写一旦集中几百台集群的集群瞬间就退化成了单机系统
[S01] 所以为了打破这种时间的连续性架构师们引入了哈希分片
[S02] 哦哈希分片就是用数学的方法把规律的数据打散
[S01] 没错我们不再直接用时间戳而是把时间戳喂给一个像MD五或者M二三这样的哈希函数哈希函数有个神奇的雪崩效应哪怕输入只差了一点点比如十二点零一分和十二点零二分输出的哈希值也会在整个数字空间里发生天翻地覆的随机跳跃
[S02] 哇所以十二点零一分的数据去了节点A一秒钟后的数据可能直接飞到了节点Z原本潮水一样涌来的数据就被均匀的轰炸到了集群的每一个角落大家终于都不摸鱼了
[S01] 是的写入牙里完美打散但是如果我们将这一点与更大的途径联系起来看架构设计永远是在做权衡哈希分片亲手扼杀了一个功能那就是我们刚才说的范围查询
[S02] 哎对哦因为数据完全水举了如果我现在要查今天下午一点到二点间的所有数据根本不知道去哪个节点找没错系统并无选择只能向整个集群所有的节点同时发送请求这就变成了极其低效的分散收集操作但这还不是最极端的因为这里才是真正有趣的地方即便有了哈希人类社会的极端行为依然会打破系统的平衡
[S01] 贾斯丁比伯引发的服务器风暴
[S02] 对，资料里这个案例非常经典在社交网络里像比伯这种拥有几百万甚至几千万粉丝的超级节点他随便发一句早安几分钟内就是上百万次点赞
[S01] 这个时候哈希也救不了命了因为这几百万个请求操作的都是同一个帖子ID无论怎么算哈希结果都指向同一台服务器
[S02] 没错听说在某些平台上这种单一账号的极端热点曾经一度吞噬了整个集群百分之三的算力这就是极端倾斜
[S01] 那系统工程师怎么反击呢面对比伯这种超级热点
[S02] 应用层的巧妙解法是加盐或者叫键拼接既然底层认死理同样的键只能去同一个节点那我们就在应用层在这个帖子ID前后人为的加上了两位的随机数比如从零零到九九
[S01] 呃这就像是为比伯的粉丝特设了一百个不同的结账通道来分流人群粉丝的点赞被随机分配到了这一百个新造出来的件上
[S02] 对这就把压力均匀分摊到了一百台机器上
[S01] 但但是等等结账是快了那如果前端页面现在需要实时显示比伯这条帖子的总点赞数我们要怎么读数据
[S02] 哎这就必须要付出代价了读取的时候系统就必须向这一百个子键分别发送请求然后把拿到的一百个结果合并起来
[S01] 为了拯救一台快要被写爆的服务器我们硬生生增加了系统的记账成本所以这种特殊待遇通常只能留给极少数的超级大V
[S02] 是的那随着数据继续增长不可避免地我们需要加SOVER这就引出了一个非常核心的问题怎么把旧数据平滑的搬到新机制上也就是再平衡机制
[S01] 这个问题我以前想过最直接的做法难道不是把哈希值除以节点总数然后取余数吗比如十二除以十余二就放二号节点
[S02] 这是一个极其繁殖觉的陷阱单次计算没问题但如果你加了一台机器节点总数从十变成了十一除数变了
[S01] 啊天呐十二除以十一的余数变成了一那也就是所有数据的余数全变了几乎全网的数据都要大搬家
[S02] 没错整个网络带宽瞬间被榨干系统直接瘫痪所以更好的策略是固定数量的分片
[S01] 固定数量就是虚拟的分片吗
[S02] 对假设我们一上来就划定一千个固定分片如果有十台机器每台就托管一百个分片当第十一台机器加入时它只需要向老机器要几个完整的分片过来就行了完全不用拆开重新算哈希
[S01] 原来如此搬家就变成了搬箱子而不是把箱子里的东西全导出来重新分那既然现在的云服务这么发达系统自动侦测负载然后全自动驾驶自己移动这些箱子岂不是最完美的呢
[S02] 嗯这就引出了一个非常重要也是极其严肃的问题完全的自动化有时候反而会带来无法预测的灾难也就是所谓的级连故障
[S01] 级连故障怎么发生的
[S02] 在分布式系统里你其实很难判定一个节点是不是真的死的可能某个节点只是因为刚好在处理一个复杂的查询响应慢了半拍
[S01] 但是其他节点误以为它挂了
[S02] 对其他节点一想哎呀它死了赶紧把它的负载接管过来结果大量的请求瞬间涌向其他节点把原本正常的节点也压垮了
[S01] 然后接着又压垮下一批节点像多米诺骨牌一样雪崩了
[S02] 完全正确所以对于移动分片这种沉重的操作适度的人工干预也就是保留一个确认按钮往往是防止系统全军覆没的安全法
[S01] 宁愿让它稍微笨一点那在日常运行的时候客端端是怎么在茫茫大海里找到正确的IP地址的呢
[S02] 这就要靠Zookeeper这样的协调服务或者是像Cassandra里用到的留言协议也就是Gossip
[S01] 留言协议听起来像是在办公室里传播八卦
[S02] 这个比喻非常贴切就是每个节点随机挑几个其他节点互相交换自己所知道的集群状态一传十十传百几秒钟内全网就都知道哪个分片在哪台机器上了
[S01] 哇没有中央指挥全靠大家私下八卦来达成共识这太奇妙了不过到目前为止我们全都在讨论按照主键比如ID来找数据但是如果我们不用ID找呢
[S02] 你说二级索引
[S01] 对啊假设你正在使用一个二手车网站汽车数据已经按照车辆ID分片了但现在你想找一辆红色的车这是二级索引这时候我们要去哪儿找整个系统完全不知道这辆车在哪儿啊
[S02] 寻找二手红汽车的难题这是分片里的硬骨头架构师只能在两种策略里选一种第一种是本地二级索引也叫分散收集模式
[S01] 也就是每个分片只管自己的一亩三分地
[S02] 对所以为了找红车系统必须去敲开每一个分片的大门问你这里有红车吗然后把结果收集起来
[S01] 写入的时候虽然简单但查询不仅慢而且容易产生长尾连迟吧只要有一个节点慢了我整个查询就得等着它
[S02] 没错所以有了第二种选择全局二级索引建立一个全局的索引局把红色统统归到某一个特定的分片上
[S01] 这样读取的时候只要查这一个分片就行了但是呃代价是每次有卖家上架一辆新的红色汽车后台可能就要跨越多个分片去更新索引
[S02] 完全正确而且为了保证数据不错乱系统可能需要动用非常复杂的分布式事务所以你看这就是分片的本质没有完美的方案永远是在权衡
[S01] 那么这一切到底意味着什么呢我们回顾一下分片它绝对不是什么魔法而是一套极致的拆解和协调的艺术从见范围到哈希从应对比伯这样的热点到二手红车的二级索引本质上我们都是在可伸缩性查询效率和系统复杂性这个不可能三角里寻找平衡
[S02] 是的也给我留下了最后一个非常挑衅性的思考你看我们将庞大的数据系统切割成分片用像Zookeeper或者流连协议来协调在热点出现时打散重组甚至还需要加入人工干预的规则来防止雪崩既然机器系统都需要通过如此精妙的规则来分权制衡和再平同
[S01] 嗯哼
[S02] 那对于我们人类社会日益膨胀的超大型公司组织甚至未来的去中心化社会结构这难道不是一种极其相似的生存法则吗
[S01] 如果一个社会系统大到单点无法承受我们该如何设计它的社会学哈希函数呢这真的是一个非常深刻的问题那今天非常感谢大家的收听下一次你在电商网站选上商品或者在社交媒体上刷新热搜的时候希望你能想起这些在后台默默运转的分片魔法保持你的好奇心我们下次来见